alors je vous entendu sur le passage il
faut comprendre que la nasa nous confie
ses réponses sur place ali talât qui
le place à ladite rc pas un objectif en
soi le premier voudrait passer d'une
personnalité devant vous un peu demain
est très solitaire fuit le plus heureux
des hommes
mais le pain sanitaire a été une
stratégie je pense
payante elle a produit des résultats
pour conduire associations et j'ai vu
liant de sincérité
aurait pu dire le 12 juillet dernier
fascination pour tout le monde bon
courage
regardez le travail et les efforts de
pédagogie qu'il a fallu pour les
professions de santé
l'échéance était hier encore les
tensions qu'il faut regarder avec
beaucoup de respect il faut être à la
fois apaisant et exigeant
et libre la france entière j'imagine et
je pense que le palace sanitaire a
conduit tout le monde sur un seul un
montant des efforts il ne semblait pas
disproportionné avec des idées et à
progresser parce que nous sommes passés
d'un peloton de tête très largement nous
avons atteint notre objectif de 50
millions de plus que ce qui était
initialement prévu et nous avons
fortement accéléré la vaccination
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire sur
ce sujet la même chose
est ce que on pourra se passer dans 15
jours ou trois semaines tulle place à
lithaire non c'est les territoires qui
ont encore besoin
est ce que le passé l'idée était
vraiment je vous parle en périgord oui
je vais par exemple en lisant de des
restaurateurs que vous êtes bon nombre
de territoires j'étais à nice et
quelques jours avant c'est un peu avant
le taux d'incidence au 15 août était
supérieur à celui des crises au 15 août
vous avez pu ouvrir au restaurant dans
les territoires vous avez le même taux
d'incidence un an plus tôt ont fermé
tout parce qu'on avait la sincérité
c'est un instrument gestion qui avait
permis d'hériter
ur et proportionnée qu'elle se trouvait
à nous faire on va le conserver dans la
poche pour éviter par tous la radio
qu'elle a bien des choses mais des
conditions sanitaires
intervenir qu'à mettre sur les
territoires où circulent moins vite de
lever certaines contraintes et de
revivre normalement anaïs et donc de
lever le passe dans les endroits où on
le met ne circulent plus c'est comme ça
qu'on va continuer tout au plus près du
territoire les choses
[Musique]